uh what is your uh what is your
settlement about the market right now
how are you feeling about bitcoin kind
of increasing having that giant increase
yesterday
i mean it was definitely a massive short
squeeze uh it was it was something that
i think a lot of people weren't
expecting um i was kind of shocked just
at the magnitude of it but uh definitely
not something on a medium term long term
time horizon that that is shocking at
all i mean we talk about uh you know
coming out here every every tuesday and
talking talking the market and talking
about a potential decoupling happening i
mean that's you know these days like we
had yesterday uh that's that's kind of
what we're looking at right like
equities down kind of chopping around
bitcoin up 15 16 percent has a lot of
sideline cash and managers all over the
world are watching uh it was definitely
something to behold
nice nice and then uh we have some
charts from you that i'd love to get to
um your first chart is talking about the
us treasury bond yields can you talk
about what this chart means
yeah so um over the last couple couple
weeks couple months here we've we've
talked a lot about the kind of the macro
environment and um since november really
the bitcoin market has has taken a big
hit and a lot of the stuff that we're
looking at from a market perspective um
you know in in terms of bitcoin was
actually quite healthy uh we weren't
seeing a huge distribution happen we
weren't seeing the traditional kind of
bear market uh you know the bear market
uh metrics that you see uh in terms of
on-chain what you're really seeing was
those kind of macro sellers right
because you had the fed kind of pivot
with inflation at
40-year highs
and really what you started to see was
the bond market started to croak and so
you saw your yields were selling off in
a big way rising which means that credit
was selling off and the equity market
took a downturn uh as well and so i
think just just recently in the middle
of february what you saw was uh yields
actually looked to have at least
momentarily topped and you saw kind of a
fed pivot with with this next chart i
have uh the fed funds uh it's basically
the fed funds futures
so here is basically a prediction market
or futures market for for how many hikes
the fed's going to get in so we have it
for march june september december and
you can kind of see a big reversal in a
lot of these uh in the middle of
february uh and at the same time
coincidentally you also saw the price of
bitcoin
bottom in a big way and so i think
that's that's the market walking back
how many hikes that the fed is going to
get in basically saying we're not gonna
be as as tight with uh future monetary
policy and you know something like
bitcoin is gonna react in a big way to
that yeah we obviously had those rates
come down a ton since uh since the
pandemic started in early 2020 but then
you have a chart talking about the
target fed fund rates um can you just
talk about what you mean here
yeah so this is basically uh this next
chart is showing uh this dynamic uh in
there are you talking about the chart we
just showed or the next the next one the
next one the uh the target
yeah so this is for the march meeting
and basically uh this is the market's
probability of of uh how many rate hikes
were going to come in march in real time
so you see basically uh until like uh
what was it like january or february
there was like the market was giving no
chance for the fed to hike whatsoever uh
twice so two rate hikes would be a 50
basis point rate hike and all of a
sudden in february uh you what you saw
was that probability blew out to 94
93.75 percent uh and this chart actually
put it up yesterday the market's now
giving the fed us a five percent
probability of two hikes and basically
95 chance of only one height and so what
we saw was kind of this peak moment of
hawkishness and and equity markets
bitcoin cratered and and the volatility
across asset classes really blew out and
so we kind of see with this chart you
see that fed put almost in real time
it's quite remarkable um and i think it
just kind of speaks to to where we are
in terms of uh the you know the
macroeconomic environment yeah and it's
giving it a zero percent chance for no
rate hike
yeah i mean
we'll see about that i think the feds
kind of cornered uh politically and so
uh you know there's a lot of pressure on
them and 25 basis points it's it's not
that much when you think of inflation at
you know seven percent maybe maybe
higher with a lot of this kind of
geopolitical uncertainty uh happening
over in europe so we'll have to wait and
see but yeah i think i think more so
than anything that 25 basis point hike
is just kind of a symbolic thing that
hey
we're doing something here uh we're not
we're not letting this thing uh just
completely run on its own gotcha and
then bitcoin is obviously a very um
volatile asset but it looks like the s p
is also pretty volatile uh based on what
you're showing here can you talk about
this s p and then the volatility index
yeah so um we've we've talked a lot
about um the vix which is this
volatility index and it's kind of a
sentiment or a gauge of risk off in
markets and so you saw in march of 2020
this this volatility index really blew
out and it was at the same time if you
overlay the bitcoin chart uh when the
vix you know really really went to like
80 it was the same time that bitcoin
created like 50 in just a matter of days
or even in the same day and so what we
see here is uh we're kind of now
entering this regime of higher
volatility uh in general for for equity
markets and so if you overlay this on on
shorter time frames with the bitcoin
price you saw that the local bottom uh
in 2022 was when the vix hit 38 so it
was like that local high in the vix was
the local bottom for bitcoin and as that
volatility came back in lowered a little
bit uh bitcoin recovered the s p
recovered and so i think we're in this
regime of of higher volatility in
general uh for equities and so
i i would expect the volatility to
remain there for bitcoin as well uh but
it just kind of shows uh you know how
shaky things are with with this kind of
regime of high high inflation low yields
uh and credit markets are kind of
gurgling under the surface hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time